un primer gran triunfo para los
congresistas demócratas de eeuu el
congreso aprobó el presupuesto fiscal de
la administración bailén que impedirá el
cierre del gobierno federal asegurando
así el financiamiento de los gastos del
gobierno por lo menos hasta el 3 de
diciembre la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes- firmó la resolución en
nueces
con esta resolución de continuidad no
solamente mantenemos el gobierno abierto
los cheques para nuestros veteranos y
los beneficiarios de la seguridad social
sino que también se trata de la ciencia
en el instituto nacional de salud la
educación de nuestros hijos la
protección de nuestro medio ambiente el
congreso evitó sobrepasar el plazo de la
medianoche de este jueves tiempo en que
el año presupuestario concluye pero aún
quedan algunos pendientes sobre la mesa
falta aprobar el aumento del techo de la
deuda y así evitar que eeuu incurra en
una suspensión de pagos de la deuda
nacional
con este tema es imperativo que el
congreso aborde el límite de la deuda de
lo contrario nuestra actual es que el
tesoro probablemente agotará sus medidas
extraordinarias para el 18 de octubre en
ese momento el tesoro se quedará con
recursos muy limitados que se agotarán
rápidamente
eeuu dejaría de pagar por primera vez en
la historia
de llegará a suceder la secretaria del
tesoro aseguró que el crédito del país
se vería afectado y enfrentarían
posiblemente una crisis financiera y una
recesión otra batalla pendiente es la
votación este jueves de un proyecto de
un billón de dólares destinado a
reconstruir la infraestructura del país